foreign
[Music]
people burning
everything destroyed it was Athena she
was doing it
I was doing it my mom had that happen
I saw what you did in the ring
I knew it had to be you say it
what if I told you Sienna here is The
Reincarnation of the goddess Athena
and you are destined to become one of
her Guardian Knights
how does it feel to be a goddess
sometimes I feel like I'm a guest in my
own body
are you ready to start your
brain
humble and committed to protecting
Athena with his life
what the hell did you do that
word that Oasis is unlike any other
before
save the rest of us from her
you think I wanted any of this
powers of liability once he learns to
control it no living man will be able to
stop
you might want to buckle up
though you were the only night in town
[Music]
you finished scraping the gum off that
lounger or what all right
I'm sorry Rich you always land on your
feet bro you're high man
they don't get that much
life but do not open it you went in to
get us jobs and all you brought back was
the hamburger
okay I don't think it's a burger you
haven't looked what the hell is that
how did you get it to do that I think he
likes me
[Applause]
oh it's acquired who said that
okay
[Applause]
re-entry systems ready
oh
what is going on
it's called the Scarab it's some kind of
world destroying weapons it's designed
to protect the toast
sometimes it does what you want and
sometimes it doesn't
I I think I cut a bus in half
Scarab chose you but it belongs to me
hello you feel for your family
makes you weak
[Music]
foreign
it's like Batman stuff Batman's a
fascist
thank you
[Music]
I'm gonna stand down I'm not the one to
fear Prime
there is a Darkness coming
it was all a dream
pull over I'm not driving
[Applause]
away
of all the threats
from both your past
and future
you've never faced anything like this
let them come
and if you don't know that you know
[Music]
foreign
I'm Star-Lord
I formed the Guardians
[Music]
met a girl fell in love
that girl died but then she came back
she came back a totaled dick oh please
he left out some important information
but
that is the gist of it
[Music]
save time every day
my sacred mission
is to create the perfect Society
things perfect
he just hated things the way they are
[Music]
I want you all to know that I'm grateful
to fight beside my friends
incinerate them
foreign
we're always searching for a family
until we found each other
are you ready
for One Last Ride
we'll all fly away together
into the forever
that beautiful sky
it's only gone
whoever it was that you were in love
with it sounds more like her hers do not
bring me into nothing
knock it off what
just never noticed how black your eyes
were they were replaced by my father as
a method of torture he he picked a
pretty set
location unknown
Charter 373
Commander Mills my ship was hit by an
undocumented asteroid
[Music]
transporting 35 passengers
on a long-range exploratory mission
[Music]
send help
crash landed on an Uncharted Celestial
body
[Music]
I've located One Survivor
a giant
the atmosphere is breathable
there's something alien out there
foreign
thank you
[Music]
my name is Miles Morales I'm Brooklyn's
one and only Spider-Man and things are
going great oh yeah you were supposed to
be here crying all right whatever
whatever wow whatever so are you like a
cow or a Dalmatian I am
spot
that's not funny
don't don't do that
miles's grades are pretty good A and AP
Physics that's my little man and a B in
Spanish what okay miles
to you and I think you know it
[Music]
miles
wanna get out of here oh when
so wait a minute there's an elite crew
with all the best spider people in it
who's the new guy this is unbelievable
this is the lobby
Miguel O'Hara the whole thing with his
idea
what's the guy gotta do to join this
spider team you can never be part of
this don't even get me started on Doctor
Strange and a little nerd back on Earth
1999.99 come on go easy on the kid he
had a terrible teacher Peter you have a
baby
I'll take it from here
miles being Spider-Man is a sacrifice
you have a choice between saving one
person
and saving every word
send me home I can't do that I can do
both Spider-Man always always what about
Uncle Ben if not for Uncle Ben most of
us wouldn't be here
[Music]
isn't what we
do we have no idea what are you doing
everyone keeps telling me how my story
is supposed to go
I'm gonna do my own thing
[Music]
stop Spiderman
and then I looked at my uncle and ah let
me guess he died
[Music]
everything
champions of this realm can do nothing
to stop us
you are very menacing I just want you to
know that
a lot has changed in the last few years
the wizard gave me superpowers
and then everybody got superpowers
all right here's the situation
the daughters of Atlas are coming to
hunt Us
children's told the power of the Gods he
ripped it from our father's core
maybe I should be writing all this down
you lost the powers child your world
will not survive this
you want these Powers come get them
now we're here all right
we have one job to do exceed the world
I don't know how we fight powers like
this
I can't do this take my powers back you
came to me so you would take them back
right
searching for worthy champion
exactly what must be done
Billy what are you doing I have to do
this we end this now yeah
we do
started from
[Music]
the team here
you're an interesting man
Scotland
you're an Avenger
[Music]
you have a daughter
but you've lost a lot of time
like me
we could help each other with that
who are you
I'm the man who can give you the one
thing you want
what's that
time
I can rewrite existence
and shatter timelines
you cannot trust him I don't care who
this guy is I just lost so much
[Music]
give us a second chance
let me make this easy for you
he will bring me what I need
or everything you call a life
you may not want her to watch this we
had a deal
you thought you could win
I don't have to win
we both just have to lose
[Music]
I'm sorry Kathy
I designed Megan to protect Katie from
feeling lonely
she will recognize you as her primary
user and when you do that you're going
to pair with her
crazy it's insane right
your goal is to protect Katie from harm
both physical and emotional
[Music]
I won't let anything harm you I love her
Megan's not a person kid you don't get
to say that
never been
very good
what are you doing couldn't sleep
occupational hazard
but your full attention
[Music]
how was that
you should probably run
don't let anything harm you ever again
have I done something to upset you Gemma
I know you think you're maximizing your
objective function
oh really
[Music]
we'd have to shut her down Jesus Christ
I thought we were friends
[Music]
I have a new primary user now me
did you make him do something bad
what's going on
[Music]
what are you I'm Megan baby